The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I.e.
When multiple lineages
of beneficial mutants
are kind of spreading in a
population at the same time,
so when these clones
are somehow interfering
with each other
in the population,
how is it that that
clonal interference effect
kind of plays out in the context
of these microbial asexual
populations.
And in particular,
in this paper, what
they were trying to measure
was the distribution of effects
of beneficial mutations.
So you've put a population
into some new environment.
There may be some beneficial
mutations that are possible.
The question is, what is
the probability distribution
of effects of those
beneficial mutations.
And this is, as
you might imagine,
a very basic quantitative
we'd like to understand just
to understand how evolution
works in new environments.
But it's actually
something that's
rather difficult to measure.
And what's interesting
here is it's
difficult to measure for
maybe a surprising reason.
This is a wonderful example
of how you kind of-- if life
gives you lemons,
then make lemonade.
Is that the expression?
OK.
All right.
So in this paper, they
set out to try and measure
the [? distribution ?] effects
of beneficial mutations.
They were unsuccessful.
But they were unsuccessful
for an interesting reason,
so then they were able
to write what I think
is a very nice science paper.
Are there any
questions about where
we are or administrative
things before we get going?
All right, so just to recap
where we were from last time,
we introduced this
Moran model, which
there's a fixed
population size, N.
Then each of these sort
of cycles, what we do
is we choose one
individual to divide
and we choose one
individual to be replaced.
And we have the daughter, say,
cell replace the cell that
was chosen for replacement.
Now in that model,
what we found was
that there's some
probability, x1,
for a new mutant with
relative fitness,
r, to actually fix
in the population.
And this is in the case
of no clonal interference.
So CI will in general be
clonal interference today.
So this is-- if it's
just this one mutation
that we're considering, then
the question of surviving
stochastic extinction
kind of at the beginning
is equivalent to the
question of being
able to fix in the
population certainly
for a beneficial mutation,
with r greater than 1.
So what we want to do
today to just start
is to try to think
about how we can
use this model and
this equation in order
to understand the
probability of fixation
when there's more than one
mutant in the population.
So here, what we found
is that this thing,
there are 2 limits that we
might want to keep track of.
So this thing goes to 1 over
n, for neutral mutations,
and it goes to S for moderately
beneficial mutations.
So S is defined as r minus 1.
So it's this for
S kind of greater
than zero, and for S times
n, much larger than 1.
So I guess this already says
that S is greater than zero,
so we could ignore that.
Are there any questions
about this before we
get going to practice using it?
All right, so I just
wanted to have us consider
a few possible situations.
All right, population size 10.
What we want to consider
a situation where
there are two mutants.
And we're going to call them A
and B, with relative fitness rA
1.01, and rB 0.99.
So A is a beneficial mutant,
and B is a deleterious mutant.
And in all these
problems, we're going
to assume that the rest of
the population has fitness 1.
So these fitnesses
of A and B, they
are as compared to the
rest of the population.
So in this case, there are
eight other individuals
with relative fitness 1.
So the question is, what is
the probability that a fixes.
Takes over the population.
Reaches number of A
individuals equal to 10.
At that stage, we're not
allowing for any new mutations
here, so then that's
the end of the dynamics.
So you can start
thinking about it,
and I will give
some options here.
All right so this is
in the Moran model,
what is the probability
that A fixes.
I'll give you 20 seconds
to think about it.
Do you need more time?
Let's go ahead and vote,
and see where we are.
Ready.
Three, two, one--
All right, we got some-- I'd
say Bs, Cs is kind of dominant.
All right.
So I'd say that there's
generally a disagreement
between B and C. Interesting.
OK.
I think that there's--
it's almost 50/50.
It is a bit splotchy, somehow.
You may need to make some effort
to find somebody that disagrees
with you, but please do so.
All right, turn to a neighbor
and try to convince them
that you're right.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
PROFESSOR: All right, let's
go ahead and reconvene and see
if anybody [INAUDIBLE].
Ready.
Three, two, one.
All right.
I'd say that there's
some migration towards C,
but it's not all the way.
All right, different arguments.
And you may want to-- D is the
argument to be made over here.
All right, so let's hear it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
So if there's one
individual from A
and one individual from
B, and basically they're
about the same fitness,
then the probability
that they should, I
guess, take over is 50%.
Well that assumes that one
of them will take over.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
is there any reason
to assume that one of
them should take over?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: I think that we
may agree that the probability
that A fixes is going
to be approximately
equal to the probability
that B fixes.
That's going to be
a useful insight.
But [INAUDIBLE]
both those things.
So we have to keep
track of that.
So that's the argument
for why it's not D.
AUDIENCE: You're welcome.
PROFESSOR: Anytime. [INAUDIBLE].
So between B and C, how
can we think about this?
You can tell us once again
what your neighbor said.
That's fine.
AUDIENCE: Why?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Um, well, my
neighbor, as opposed to me,
made the correct decision to try
to think about it intuitively
instead of trying to get
through all the math.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Always good to think about
things intuitively rather
than-- that's--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
So A is very
slightly beneficial,
and so it is just
a little bit more
likely to fix than
a neutral mutation.
PROFESSOR: OK, and how can
we quantify this statement?
That I know I said that I
didn't like math, but you know,
every now and then
we should look at it.
Yeah, so this statement
that A is approximately
a neutral mutation.
How is it that we can--
how do we know that?
I mean did--
AUDIENCE: We have criteria
for nearly neutral.
PROFESSOR: Yes, we have a
criteria for nearly neutral.
What does that-- what does
it mean to be nearly neutral?
AUDIENCE: The
magnitude of S times N
is much, much less than one.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
S times N is much
less than one, which
means that it's nearly neutral.
What that means is that
the probability of fixing
is the same as if it
were a neutral mutation,
or approximately the same.
And is that the case here?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
S is 0.01, so 1/100.
N is 10.
So S times N is equal to 0.1.
Which means that both-- so
A is maybe nearly neutral.
Is B nearly neutral?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Yes, so both A
and B are nearly neutral.
One of them is an advantageous
mutant, one is a deleterious.
But in this
population size, they
both behave as if
they're nearly neutral.
But in a larger
population, so if
we had a million
individuals, would these
be neutral mutations?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No.
So the question of
whether something behaves
as a neutral mutation depends
upon the population size
via this relation.
So that's-- and then
how do we go from there?
AUDIENCE: Well the probability
of a neutral mutation
[INAUDIBLE] population
is going to be [? 1/S ?].
PROFESSOR: That's right.
A neutral mutation will fix
a probability of one group.
So indeed, we're
going to get this.
And we need to
highlight that we can--
you have to be very careful
about just sticking things
into formulas.
So you may remember
that the probability
of a beneficial mutant fixing
in the population is S.
But that's only for S times
N being much larger than one,
and that's when there's
no clonal interference.
When you don't have to compete
with other beneficial mutants
in the lineage.
We're going to see an
example of this in a moment.
But if you just
have a single mutant
in the population, that's
beneficial in the sense of it's
not neutral.
Then probably the fixation is S.
And of course, this
is nonsensical, right?
Because you can't--
it wouldn't make any--
certainly it wouldn't--
given that you say oh well,
if it were neutral, it would
fix with a probability of 10%.
And then you say oh, but if
it's an advantageous mutant,
it can't fix with a
probability less than that.
So this is nearly neutral,
fixation probability is 10%.
Are there any questions
about that argument?
So let's consider a
different problem.
So now, we're going to consider
a population that's larger.
So it's going to be the
same situation, where
we have these two mutants
present as single individuals.
So what we want to know now is
the probability that B fixes.
Once again, you should
start thinking about this
while I type it.
Oh, there was one
other thing I wanted
to say, actually, over here.
If we modeled these
population dynamics
using differential equations--
so instead of doing the Moran
process where we stochastic
dynamics of division,
replacement, and so forth, if
you write down a differential
equation describing
this situation,
what is the probability
that A fixes?
I'm going to give
you five seconds.
AUDIENCE: One.
PROFESSOR: All right, one.
OK, so you don't get to vote.
Indeed, 1.
So if you had written down
the differential equation,
then there's no
randomness there.
Whichever mutant has
the largest fitness
will fix with probability 1.
OK?
OK, probability that B fixes.
So this-- you show
me both [INAUDIBLE].
I'll give you 20, 30
seconds to think about this.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is there
just one [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
All right, so this kind
of-- that's why-- yeah.
So it's just the same thing.
And so that's a single A
mutant and a single B mutant.
Single A, single
B. But you should
know how to calculate these
things if I tell you that they
were some other number.
Do you need more time?
So in general, if you don't look
at me when I ask that question,
I'm going to take that as
meaning that you're still
thinking about it.
Is that how I should
interpret that?
OK.
Let's go ahead and vote just so
that we can see where we are.
OK, ready.
Three, two, one.
All right.
We're all over the place.
That's great.
Because that means your
neighbor will either
be able to help you or
confuse you, or do something.
So let's [INAUDIBLE].
There's a million--
population size 1,000,000.
We have two mutants
in the population.
One has relative fitness
2, one has relative fitness
of-- an advantage of 1%.
One thing to be careful
of here is the equation
that we have for probability
of fixation here-- ah.
There's one more thing
that I should say.
It's for S. Well, it's
an S much less than 1.
Just for-- so this is for a
moderately-beneficial mutation.
Otherwise, you have to
use the full approach.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: All right.
Go ahead and turn
to your neighbor,
and try to convince them
that you've figured this out.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
PROFESSOR: So everybody
should be talking to somebody.
What do you think?
Well it's OK to not know,
but that's why you--
you should either join them,
or if you look behind you,
there's someone else that
looks very, uh-- All right,
why don't-- let's-- OK.
Let's-- what's that?
AUDIENCE: I said my reasons
are always good reasons.
PROFESSOR: They're
always good reasons.
They'll be educational.
All right, let's go
ahead and reconvene.
I know that there were a
lot of different guesses
on this problem,
which means maybe
that the conversations were
scattered or difficult,
or it was difficult to converge.
But still, let's see if
it made any difference.
Ready.
Three, two, one.
OK.
All right, yeah.
So I'd say that the
conversations have helped.
But we're still a
fair distribution
between maybe A, C, and D still.
But-- yeah.
Does somebody want to
give an explanation
for one of those three,
or something else?
Yeah, [? John. ?]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE],
then you know [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: And it indicates
that [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Perfect.
OK.
Now I just want to
make sure that we all
agree on this logic.
So if the only thing we
had was the mutation B,
then the probability of
fixation would be 1% because,
in that case-- is this a
nearly neutral mutation?
No.
So that means that its
probability of fixation
is going to be around
S, in this case, 1.01.
OK, but--
AUDIENCE: But now A is
there, so you-- first, you
expect that-- you expect
the probability of B
to fix to be lower than 1%.
A fixes in half of the cases.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
AUDIENCE: So in these cases,
[? B's ?] not going to fix.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: So my answer is C,
but I mean, it's a bit of a--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, no,
no, I mean it's-- no,
but that's precisely
what's happening.
So for B to fix, it requires
two things to happen.
First, B has to survive
stochastic extinction.
And-- so we're going to
multiply these probabilities--
A doesn't survive.
We're going to discuss in
a moment what this really
means in terms of surviving
stochastic extinction.
But when a new mutation
appears in the population,
it will either relatively
quickly go extinct,
or it will relatively
quickly become established,
is what we call that.
What that means
is that it will--
if it's a beneficial
mutation, it
will take over unless it's
outcompeted by someone else.
So it has to be that B
survives stochastic extinction,
and A doesn't survive
this initial phase.
And this thing-- so that
means that the probability
that B fixes is going
to be-- well, OK.
The probability that B
survives stochastic extinction
is going to be 1%.
The probability that A survives
is 1/2, so the probability
that it doesn't
survive is also 1/2.
Now the half, just
to remind ourselves,
comes from this thing x1, for
A. There was this [INAUDIBLE].
This thing is what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
So this thing very
quickly goes to zero.
So this is 1/2 to
the millionth power.
So that's zero.
So we just get 1 minus 1/2.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: But what
are we assuming?
It's not clear to
me in this case.
Because we're assuming
they're completely independent
and we can multiply--
PROFESSOR: That's right.
AUDIENCE: Together, so--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's right.
And I would say that for--
from the same [INAUDIBLE]
the population of
a million, these
are totally non-interacting
processes, for all intents
and purposes.
If you were down to a
population size of 10,
then you might have
to worry that they're
going to interact more.
But in this process of--
in this Moran process,
you have a million individuals.
It's true that this
is twice as likely
to be chosen to divide
as a normal cell,
but you're talking
about a million cells
in that population.
So the correction to the things
that you're worrying about
is a [INAUDIBLE] 10 to the 6.
AUDIENCE: And so the
thing [INAUDIBLE], yeah.
But if rA and rB were closer, I
should [INAUDIBLE] correction--
PROFESSOR: No.
It's not about how close rA
and rB are to each other.
Even if they had the exact
same relative fitness.
Even if they were
both 2 or both 1.01,
then they would still
be non-interacting.
And that's just because they're
in this sea of individuals.
AUDIENCE: But the thing
that I'm worried about
is, for example, rA
could take over quickly,
and then rB could take over.
And that--
PROFESSOR: OK--
AUDIENCE: Would not be--
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK so--
AUDIENCE: And that's
not reasonable.
[? If this case ?] is rA
[INAUDIBLE], then rB--
the effective rB--
PROFESSOR: Right.
OK So there is one
problem-- You're right.
So I should be careful.
If the two mutants have
exactly the same fitness,
then if they both survive
stochastic extinction,
they're going to-- then
you can describe everything
as a differential.
And this is the distinction
between this initial phase
of trying to become
established as
compared to the later dynamics
in that the established means
that if it's a beneficial
mutation, it will spread,
and basically deterministically.
So in that situation, if you
had two mutants, and both
of relative fitness
1.01, then they both
would try to survive
stochastic extinction.
And let's say that
they both did.
Then they would both spread in
the population exponentially.
Of course, given that
the initial dynamics
are stochastic,
then it would still
be the case that one of
them would just happen
to be above the other one.
But then they would grow
exponentially together.
That's a more
complicated situation
than what we're
going to discuss.
And that would
actually be very rare.
Because each one
of these mutants
would only have a 1%
chance of surviving.
So only one in 10 to
the 4 times would you
end up with both
of these mutants
surviving stochastic extinction.
Any other questions about-- so
I just want to be clear here.
So this is when A is equal to
1-- the number of A individuals
is 1, the number of B
individuals equal to 1.
There was a question, what if
we started with A equal to 10.
So let's say the-- yeah.
let's?
Say we start with 10A
and 10B, for example.
So instead of starting with just
mutant A and one mutant B, now
we have 10 of each.
So we're changing
things symmetrically.
What's going to be the
probability that B fixes,
approximately?
This is going to be a
little funny somehow.
But OK, we'll-- just think
about it for 15 seconds.
What's going to the probability
that B fixes in this case?
All right, I'm worried you
guys are now even trying.
AUDIENCE: Could you
repeat the question?
PROFESSOR: Sure, yeah.
OK.
So we just did the problem,
we had a single mutant A
and a single mutant B. And
we found the probability
that B fixes was 0.005.
Now I want to know
is, does anything
change instead of having
a single A and single B,
now what we have is 10 A, 10 B,
and then the rest of them just
being [INAUDIBLE] one.
So it's not fancy math.
But it's still, I can
see, a little confused.
I just wanted you
to see where we are.
We'll use the same options
here, whatever is closest.
And we can argue about what
close means in a moment.
All right, ready,
three, two, one.
So it's kind of some
A's and B's, some E's.
All right.
Well, we'll talk about it.
Maybe we'll jump ahead
to the group discussion,
just because I
don't want to spend
too much time on this problem.
But these are the
kinds of problems,
I think, it's very
important to practice with,
because they just
develop your intuition
for the stochastic dynamics
that occur in populations.
It's going to be something
like B. You know,
that's not why I put B in there.
But let's just see how it goes.
And the way to find
the answer here
is the same as what we did
before, except that now we
have to think about these
processes somewhat differently.
So first of all, in
order for B to fix,
it requires that still B has to
survive stochastic extinction.
So we still have
the same 0.01 here.
But now we have to think
about the probability
that A doesn't survive.
And that's going to
change now, right?
Oh, I should be-- OK.
Yeah, OK.
I forgot that we had 10 here.
We could calculate what it
is, and actually, maybe we
should have.
Well, let's calculate that.
All right, so this
is x1 for B. We still
have 1.01 to the
mill-- so we can still
ignore this bottom part.
But what it's going
to be is, oh, no,
but there's this x10 of B,
where you have 10 individuals.
So this is 1 minus
1.01 to the 10th power.
AUDIENCE: But we have
clonal interference here.
PROFESSOR: Right now what
we're trying to understand
is if only we had B-- this
is the probability that we're
trying to calculate
this part of it.
So if we ignore A, what's
the probably that B
survives stochastic extinction?
Oh, this is fine.
So it's a modest change.
Because this is
going to be 1 minus.
So this thing is around 1.1,
because 1 plus x to the n
is around 1 plus nx for
nx much less than 1.
So this is 1.1.
OK, so right.
So this is around 0.1.
So indeed, I'd forgotten
that there was 10.
So given that we have 10 of
these B individuals starting,
they may survive.
Ignoring A right now, just
on their own dynamics,
they may survive, or they may
drift down to 0 and go extinct.
And indeed, even starting
with 10 individuals--
10 B individuals-- you
actually still expect them
to go extinct.
And this, actually,
calculation is
very relevant for what
we're about to think about,
which is this
question of what does
it mean to be established
in a population.
And already you can kind of
see what it's going to mean.
How big do you need to
get in the population
before you're likely to survive?
AUDIENCE: 1/s.
PROFESSOR: 1/s.
Because you can
basically see how
this is going to work
out in this calculation,
that the number you have
to get to to be established
is around 1/s.
So in this case, you have to
get to around 100 individuals
before you are going to be more
likely than not to survive.
Let's see if we can
figure out this problem.
All right, so we had
0.1 was the probability
that B would survive
stochastic extinction.
But then in order
for B to fix, it
has to not only survive
stochastic extinction,
but also A has to not survive.
And we can figure out what
that is going to be here.
This is that term.
And then we need another one.
So this is x of 10 of
A. And this is, again,
going to be 1 minus
1/2 to the 10th power.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, right.
So it's always good to
memorize a few of these things.
2 to the 10 is
approximately 1,000.
But we want not this.
So we're going to
subtract this 1 away.
So we're going to get
10 to the minus 3.
Do you guys see
how that-- right?
So given that we start
with 10 individuals of A
with a relative fitness
2, then there's only a 1
in 1,000 chance that
those A individuals
are going to go extinct.
So the probability that B is
going to fix in this situation
is rather close to
10 to the minus 4.
So it's somewhere
in between there.
Are there any questions
about how that came about?
I feel like there's a fair
amount of unhappiness.
So it could be
the logic of this,
or it could be the calculation
of one of the two terms
or it could be something else.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
Where did you get
x10 B, the probably
of x of B surviving again?
PROFESSOR: You want to know
this term or that term?
AUDIENCE: The first term.
PROFESSOR: Right,
the first term.
So the first term
is just asking,
if there were no A, what would
be the probability that B would
survive stochastic extinction?
That's the same as the
probability that it would fix,
because it's a
beneficial mutation,
and if B is the
only thing, right?
So we use this equation.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
PROFESSOR: So we
use this equation,
except that this
thing just goes to 1,
so we're just left with this.
But this equation is
assuming that there's
just one of the
mutant individuals.
Otherwise if you say x sub
i, then it's r to the i here.
So that was the equation
that was derived in chapter
six of Evolutionary Dynamics.
But I think that that's not
the only thing that people are
unhappy about, so please-- no?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: A question
on why don't you
need to take into
account B doesn't
survive-- that probability
that B doesn't survive?
For that first question that's
not on the board right now,
I guess, for the nearly
neutral [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, so this was the
very first one that we did?
OK.
Right, so you want to know--
AUDIENCE: Why don't you need
to take into account the
probably that B doesn't survive?
PROFESSOR: All right,
so in this problem,
it's just that they all behave
as if they were just neutral.
So the probability of each of
these 10 individuals fixing
in the population is
the same, essentially.
So they each have a 1 in 10
probability of surviving.
And in this case, I
would say that if things
are nearly neutral,
you don't talk
about this idea of surviving
stochastic extinction,
because you can't get
big enough to the point
where you are really
guaranteed to survive
stochastic extinction.
Because even if you've gone to
occupy 75% of the population,
what's your probability
of fixing at that stage?
If you're nearly neutral
and you get up to 75%,
you have a 75% chance of fixing.
In the case in the
neutral mutations,
there's no analogous
idea of what
it means to be established,
because you could always
just go back and go extinct
with finite probability.
This question?
Well, it's looking more
and more likely to show up
on the midterm in two weeks.
So now is your opportunity
to ask a question about it.
AUDIENCE: Can you talk
about and establish
how you got [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
OK, this is a good question.
So when we talk about a mutation
becoming established, that's
asking-- of course, we know
that even a rather beneficial
mutation, say
something that confers
advantage of a few percent,
will probably go extinct.
However, if it gets up to
be a large enough fraction
or a number of the
population, then the dynamics
are going to be well described
by a differential equation
where it won't go extinct.
So this is established mutation.
And this, again, we
really talk about only
for beneficial mutations,
because other mutations
can't really get established.
They could still
stochastically fix.
But it's still stochastic
up to the very end.
And so the question is, at
what number in the population
do you had to get before you
are expected to take over
the population, assuming that
other new mutants don't arise.
That corresponds
to asking, OK, this
is the probability
of fixation when
you have i individuals
in the population.
And this is what we saw before.
This is permutation
with relative fitness r.
You have i individuals in the
population, total population
size n.
And this becoming
established means that xi
is approximately equal to 1.
Now, in these
situations, r to the n
is, again, very, very large.
So this thing we can ignore.
So this is really the same
thing as asking that 1 minus.
And this never gets to
be exactly equal to 1.
But what now we're
really asking is
that this thing is close to 1.
And this equivalent
is saying that--
what do we want to say--
that 1 over r to the i
is much less than 1.
And well, that means that r to
the i is much greater than 1.
So this is really saying
that what you want
is i times s to be
much greater than 1.
So n established,
which is, in this case,
it's the i such
that this is true.
It has to be much
greater than 1 over s.
And indeed, I think that when
i is equal to 1 over s, then
I think the probability
of extinction is 1 over e,
if you do the math.
So that means that this is kind
of the crossing over point,
where you're more likely
than not to survive.
And just to be concrete,
for many of the mutations
we're talking about and that
you read about in Roy's paper,
s was a few percent.
So this is saying that the
population is established
when the number of these
mutants gets up to above 30
or a few times 30, so
maybe 100 individuals
means that it's unlikely to
go extinct stochastically.
So really, it's once you
get to this n established,
then the population
will grow exponentially
in the population.
And it's going to
spread exponentially
with an advantage s relative
to the rest of the population.
So this discussion is actually
very useful for the next thing
we want to talk about.
But are there any question
about how we got this?
AUDIENCE: You said the
probability of going extinct
is 1 over e.
PROFESSOR: Right
AUDIENCE: So xi is
approximately equal to 1.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So this is the probably
of going extinct?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: So the probability
of going extinct here,
if you have i individuals,
is 1 over this guy.
So it's 1 over 1
plus s to the i.
And then if i times s
is 1 but s is small--
this is one of those
definitions of e to the x
that, I don't know, do
you guys remember this?
It's like, oh my goodness,
e to the x is the limit.
No, no, x is up there.
Boy, you guys are taxing me.
All right.
This is x over n to the n.
And this limit is
n goes to infinity.
Is this?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Do we agree?
OK.
This makes sense, right?
So this is just the
equivalent of saying
that if i times s equal
to 1 but s is small,
then this thing is around e.
If you're confused, I
don't want to get into this
too much, because it's
not quite central to what
we're talking about.
But come up and talk
to me after the class,
and we'll derive this together.
So the idea is that when you've
reached a population size of 1
over s, then you have a 1 over
e probability of going extinct.
So e pops up at all
sorts of weird locations.
This is why you hear about it.
So what I want to
do now is I want
to discuss this idea of clonal
interference a little bit more,
in particular ask, in
what situation will
we have clonal interference?
Or equivalently, when can we
ignore clonal interference?
Can somebody say
in words when we're
going to be able to ignore the
effect of clonal interference?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] so large
that there's a very limited
match that goes to--
PROFESSOR: OK, I
think we're going
to have to be careful here.
Because you're saying, oh
well, if the population
is large enough,
then you're saying,
oh, the mutations
won't interact, right?
AUDIENCE: Not in the beginning.
PROFESSOR: Right.
They don't interact
at the beginning.
I think that statement
I'm very happy with.
But the problem is that
if they both survive
stochastic extinction
and they start spreading,
then they do start to interact
in this large population.
AUDIENCE: Didn't you
just say that once they
survive stochastic extinction,
they pretty much behave like--
PROFESSOR: They behave
deterministically.
But the thing is that if you
have two sub-populations that
are exponentially
growing-- and there
are these very nice diagrams
that I guess in Roy's paper
they don't show.
Which is if you look at somehow
the population kind of changing
as a function of time, you can
think about, OK, well, this
is, let's say, constant
population size.
And it starts out all
being a particular type.
We'll say there's
some population of A.
But now a new mutation
arises and survives
stochastic extinction.
It starts spreading
in the population.
All right, this may
be mutant B. But then
if another mutant appears over
here that's even more fit,
then it can actually
spread faster.
And indeed, it can cause the
B lineage to get out competed.
So we start out with population
A. Mutant B is more fit than A.
It's spreading exponentially.
But some time later
mutation C appears.
Now this C lineage
is more fit than B,
so it's able to
spread exponentially.
And indeed, it out competes
B. So this is exactly what
we mean by clonal interference.
These two lineages are
interfering with each other.
So this is, indeed,
clonal interference.
And there have been
these drawings out.
For every 20 years, people
have been thinking about this.
Like Lenski wrote some classic
papers thinking about this.
Recently, Michael
Desai at Harvard
has done some really
beautiful work
where he takes these
evolving yeast populations.
He does high
resolution-- resolution
in both senses,
temporal as well as
kind of deep sequencing in the
population-- where he could
actually directly see these
lineages spreading and then
being out-competed.
And he sees multiple
mutations spreading
through the population
together because they
were attached on some genome.
It's a very nice paper.
I almost had you guys
read it, so it's maybe
Nature in 2012, '13.
I don't know, possibly '12.
So this is the idea of
clonal interference.
So it's after the initial
stochastic dynamics
have played out.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is the [? spectre ?]
[INAUDIBLE] you call that
[? clonal ?] [? interference? ?]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so that is a
result of clonal interference,
because it's saying that that
half arises because B, maybe,
if it did survive, it may
still get out-competed by A.
So that's clonal interference.
AUDIENCE: Did you say the
populations of mutations
weren't [? correct? ?]
PROFESSOR: Right.
So the idea is that they
don't interact initially.
Because when the mutations
are present at a very low
frequency, then they're
really interacting
with the bulk, the rest of the
population, 10 to the 6 there.
However, if they survive
stochastic extinction
and they start spreading
in the population,
then there's the possibility
of clonal interference.
AUDIENCE: But wouldn't that
change that [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: No.
I think that's why
it's at the half.
Because this factor of a
half is really just saying
that even if B survives
stochastic extinction,
it only has a 50-50
shot of actually being
able to take over, because
there's a 50% chance
it's going to experience
clonal interference
with this A lineage that's
going to out-compete it.
Maybe if you're unhappy
about that statement,
harass me afterwards.
So from this
discussion, though, how
can we think about
the importance
of clonal interference?
In particular, there are
going to be two time scales.
And the question
of whether there's
going to be significant
clonal interference
is related to which of
these time scales is larger.
So what might the
time scales be?
Or at least one of
the time scales?
AUDIENCE: I guess
one should probably
be the time to be established.
PROFESSOR: Right.
To be established.
AUDIENCE: To reach the
[INAUDIBLE] [? establish. ?]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So the actual time that it takes
from when a mutation appears
to when it becomes established--
I mean, there is a time there.
But it ends up not being
the relevant thing,
because that's the regime
where they're not actually
interacting, that the
mutant lineages are not
interacting anyways.
So there's a sense
that it doesn't quite
matter how long that takes,
at least to first order.
AUDIENCE: How much time did it
take to reach some population
size [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Right.
OK, yeah.
So one of them is
going to be that it's
the time to go from
established to fixation.
So it's actually the
next time scale there.
And actually, the time
to get established
is actually rather short.
So a mutation appears, and most
of the time it goes extinct.
But the ones that don't
go extinct actually
get established rather
quickly, because that's
a biased sampling
over the trajectories.
But there is a rather
significant time
that it takes for
the lineage to go
from being established
to actually fixing
in the population.
So this is kind of how long
it takes for a mutation
to take over a population.
We might call this the
time to spread or so.
And it turns out
that that time--
what is it going to depend on?
AUDIENCE: s.
PROFESSOR: It's
going to depend on s.
So as s goes up,
then this goes down.
All right, perfect.
All right, let's just
go put a 1 over s there.
And this is because it's
going to grow exponentially
in the population.
And then how else is
it going to depend on?
AUDIENCE: n.
PROFESSOR: n, right.
And indeed, this is going
to be the log of n times s.
It's really n over
n established.
Because the idea is that you
start out at n established.
You grow exponentially with
rate s until you kind of take
over the population, size n.
And this s appears because
it's 1 over n established.
Because this in the log
is really the population
size divided by n established.
So this is one time scale.
Do you guys understand why
it should be like this?
Right.
And what's the other time
scale that's relevant here?
AUDIENCE: How fast
mutations occur.
PROFESSOR: How fast
mutations-- yes.
AUDIENCE: How long you have
to wait from one mutation
to the next mutation.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So this is how long you have
to wait for one mutation.
So this is T, what we
might call T mutation.
Now it's a little
bit subtle to think
about what this should be.
But it should say
something about the time
it takes for mutations to
appear in the population.
So let's go ahead and just
guess what this might be.
T mutation should
be equal to what?
All right, so it could be--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So I guess I'm trying to get you
to think about what this should
mean to be relevant for
determining the time
scales of whether clonal
interference is important.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Mu is the
probability per generation
of having a beneficial
mutation of magnitude s.
Mu is kind of the mutation rate.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
But we'll just
assume that there's
only one kind of
beneficial mutation,
and every beneficial
mutation has magnitude s,
for simplicity.
So it's mutation rate.
It's a beneficial mutation
rate per generation
of leading to mutation s.
And you can just also say,
if you have no idea what
I'm talking about, it's fine.
But it's worth spending a
little bit of time thinking
about what should
be the relevant time
scale to compare to this.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So Mu is per
organism [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: That's right.
And it's OK if you
find this confusing,
because this is subtle.
But if you think about
it for 30 seconds, then
maybe you'll be fertile ground
for the discussion to follow.
All right, let's go ahead and
vote and see where we are.
Ready, three, two, one.
All right.
This is very nice.
Almost everybody is saying C.
Although it really should be D.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
So 1 over s is units of time,
and 1 over mu is [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, that's an
interesting statement.
I mean, I guess this
is a relative fitness.
AUDIENCE: So s is mu.
AUDIENCE: But right
there, you have s units
of time, 1/s units of time.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so
the problem of this
is this is all in units
of generation time.
Because this is
really telling us
about the number of generations.
So what is going on?
Because 1 over mu n should
also be a time, right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah, I'm not sure
if-- yeah, I mean,
since this is all
in generations,
I'm not sure if we even have
to-- yeah, I think it's OK.
AUDIENCE: n times s
has to be [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I like
that statement.
But then he, I mean--
AUDIENCE: Well, then
you have 1 over mu.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I know.
But then, this should
have units of time.
I agree with your statement, but
I also sort of agree with his,
the 1 over s here.
You know that's the problem.
AUDIENCE: Everything
is basically unitless.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, but I
think that it's really
because everything's
in units of generation.
So really, it's all
unitless, except for mu.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What I
don't understand
is why how beneficial
the mutation is
should play into how--
PROFESSOR: No, I agree.
This is subtle.
So let's imagine this is time.
Now, 1 over mu n is
telling us how much time
there is between the
initial appearance
of these beneficial mutants.
So here we get a
beneficial mutation.
But what do you think
is going to happen
to that beneficial mutation?
Yeah, that guy's dead.
It comes up.
How long do we have to wait for
the next beneficial mutation?
AUDIENCE: 1 over mu n.
PROFESSOR: 1 over mu n.
Is it going to be exactly that?
Is going to be
peaked around that?
All right, verbal
answer, what is
going to be the
probability distribution
between successive appearances
of this beneficial mutation?
Ready, three, two, one.
AUDIENCE: Exponential.
PROFESSOR: It's
exponentially distributed.
So there might be another one
that's coming through here.
What do you think is going
to happen to that guy?
AUDIENCE: Probably dead.
PROFESSOR: Oh, he's dead.
OK.
Another one.
So these guys are appearing.
But if the magnitude
of s is, say,
0.02, that means we have to
wait for 50 of these things
to appear before we
expect that one of them
is actually going
to get established.
And established means
it gets up to 1 over s.
So this guy, once
he's established,
he's going to grow
exponentially in the population.
But the idea is that the time
scale here of 1 over mu n
is the time between
successive appearances
of this beneficial mutation,
whereas as 1 over mu ns
is the time scale between
successive establishments
of these beneficial mutations.
And it's only if
they get established
that they're relevant.
So that's why the t mutation
established is 1 over mu ns.
Now, no clonal interference
means that one of these
is larger than the other one.
So no clonal
interference means is it,
A, this guy's larger,
or B, this guy's larger?
So larger, question mark.
This one?
That one?
All right, think about
this for 15 seconds,
just to make sure that
we're-- make sure.
We're asking, if there's
no clonal interference,
it means that one of these is
much larger than the other one.
Which one?
Ready, three, two, one.
It means that this thing is
much larger than this one.
So this thing has to be much
larger than t establish to fix.
Because if it's the
case this time scale
is very large compared to
this time scale of spreading,
then the mutations don't
ever clonal interfere.
I think it's very important
that you can reconstruct
this whole argument
because it has
all the ingredients of
the dynamics in terms
of stochastic, and
then deterministic.
If you find this stuff
confusing, please
go through it with a friend
or come to me after class.
So what we went to do
for the last 20 minutes
is, then, talk
about Roy's paper.
And I think that this paper
is interesting and subtle.
It's a little bit hard
to tell how much of it
is an experimental kind of
straight up demonstration
or how much of it is that
it's just a way of getting
you to think new thoughts.
It certainly is a way to get
At least I felt that it
had that effect on me,
and that after
reading it, I just
got very excited
about all the dynamics
that were at play
here, and how out
of the complexity of
this clonal interference
process, maybe, in
some cases, there
might be some even simpler
phenomenological type
description of
what was going on.
But I think that what is very
interesting about that paper
is this idea that what they
really wanted to measure
was this probability
distribution
of beneficial mutations.
So what we mean by that is that
different beneficial mutations
will have different effects.
And in particular, you could
imagine a thought experiment
where you take an E. coli cell.
How big is the E.
coli genome roughly?
And just like it's always good
to have guideposts for how long
ago things happened, it's
also good to have guideposts
for things like it's
just good to have
a few genome sizes memorized.
Now does anybody know
the E. coli genome?
AUDIENCE: 2,000 base pairs.
PROFESSOR: 2,000 base pairs?
AUDIENCE: 2,000 [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: No, I just want to
make sure that we're-- yeah.
Yeah, it's a bit more than that.
It's a few million base
pairs, three or four,
depending on the strain.
But you can imagine a thought
experiment where you go in,
and at every base pair you
make the three possible point
mutations.
So then you can imagine having
10 million different strains
that are each
different at one site.
And then what we can do is we
can plot the rate of population
growth in some environment.
So this is gamma.
It's the 1 over n dn/dt,
basically division, right?
Normalized by the
wild type division.
I'm sorry, that's
supposed to be down there.
So this is gamma over
gamma of wild type.
And this could be E. coli
in LB or minimal media or at
30 [? ci ?].
You pick some
reasonable environment.
Question is, if you draw
the histogram of what
this thing should look
like, what should it be?
Now what I'm going to ask
you to do is, in 30 seconds,
draw something on
your sheet of paper.
This is supposed
to be a frequency
or histogram over those 10
million point mutations.
So we haven't actually
done this experiment.
But I think we have
made all possible gene
knockouts in E. coli, so
removing each of the genes.
And we've done that in E. coli.
We've done it in yeast.
And indeed, in yeast, they're
actually making and measuring
the division rate for
all pairwise knockouts.
So they're some fraction
of the way through.
They published their first
10 million measurements
for the division rate of the
pairwise knockouts in yeast.
This is Charlie
Boone at Toronto.
It's an amazing data set.
Sorry, this is a simpler one.
So this is just if we make
a histogram of the growth
rate of E. coli, all 10
million possible point
mutations in E.
coli, what do you
think it's going to look like?
And I'm going to come by, and if
I don't see distribution drawn
on your sheet of
paper, then you'll
get to draw it up here on
the board for all of us.
AUDIENCE: It's totally
a distribution.
PROFESSOR: OK.
All right.
AUDIENCE: He was coming.
He was coming to me.
PROFESSOR: All right.
And what I find interesting
about this exercise
is that you get all
possible distributions.
No, but it's funny, because it's
like a super basic question.
And somehow we don't necessarily
think about it, or whatnot.
Could somebody
throw out what they
think maybe should be going on?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I'm expecting
a large fraction to get 0.
PROFESSOR: So it could
be that they're all here.
AUDIENCE: You know, most will
start-- not most, but large
fractions [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So it could be that
a large fraction of these point
mutations, and the
cell is just dead.
So this is what you call a
pessimistic view of nature
or of life.
And he has trouble crossing the
street because he's never sure.
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: I actually think that
there's a much larger fraction
where it's exactly the
same, because they've
got a lot of point mutations
that are just substitutions.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, OK.
So lots of them, maybe.
So these are the two
polar views of the world,
that nothing matters,
or you're all dead.
AUDIENCE: I think
it can reconcile it.
I think you can say--
PROFESSOR: OK, well, now I
think you're being too-- OK,
how are we going
to reconcile them?
AUDIENCE: So we know that
there's the [? third ?]
[? bubble, ?] right?
PROFESSOR: Sure.
AUDIENCE: And so there's
probably at least 1/3
somewhere it just doesn't
matter at all, where
you get the same code.
PROFESSOR: Although there
are cases, actually,
where even silent
mutations end up changing
protein at an expression level.
All right, but I don't
know if this reconciles
the two views of the world.
So some people have drawn
things that look like this.
Some people will draw it,
and things look like this.
Yeah.
And we have a
uniform distribution.
If you're going to make a null
model, I mean, I don't know.
So I would say that we
have enough information
to say something about what
this thing should look like.
So first of all, some fraction
of genes are indeed essential.
For 10% or 20% of the genes,
you remove it, the cell is dead.
That doesn't mean that 10%
to 20% of point mutations
will lead to a lethal
phenotype, but it
means that if you do inactivate
or knock out that gene,
then it will be lethal.
So that means that there are
indeed some set of these point
mutations that are
going to be lethal,
but it's going to be small.
And I don't know what
the actual number
would be, but maybe 1 in 10
to the 4, something small.
Because it's probably only
10% the locations on the gene
would actually knock it out.
I'm making up that number.
The protein guys would
have a much better sense.
But it's going to
be a small number.
It might only be 1% of
the mutations, actually,
would actually knock out
the function of the protein.
And then not all of the genome
actually codes for proteins.
So you start multiplying
small numbers together,
and you get something
that's rather small.
But there will be some
number of mutations there.
However, the vast
majority of mutations
will have no measurable
fitness effect.
So indeed, this thing kind
of peaks here, and then
rather sharply comes down.
And this is on a linear
scale, or something like that.
So the width might
indeed be a few percent.
But actually, probably
even less, maybe 1%,
or half, something small.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How skewed is it?
PROFESSOR: So on a linear
scale, it doesn't look skewed.
On a log scale, I think it does.
I mean, in the sense that
if you plot log frequency
on this axis, then
there's a longer tail
on the left than on the right.
But I'd say on a linear scale,
it's just pretty sharp function
there.
AUDIENCE: So people
have measured that?
PROFESSOR: Certainly for
all the gene knockouts,
we have measured this.
And even that distribution
is sharply peaked.
So the point mutation
distribution's
going to be even
more tightly peaked.
AUDIENCE: For most
genes, you can just
knock them out and [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Sorry.
So for most genes, at least
in many environments--
and of course, it depends on
what environment you measure.
But for most genes,
you can knock them out.
Certainly in rich media,
most genes you can knock out.
This, as I said, might be
1 in 10 to the minus 3, 4.
I might be off by a couple
orders of magnitude.
But the point is that this is
a small fraction over here.
Most are here.
And there will be some point
mutations that come down here.
But on a linear scale, it's
going to be very small.
Now from the standpoint
of a population evolving
to a new environment,
which mutations
are we most interested in?
AUDIENCE: The beneficial.
PROFESSOR: The
beneficial mutations.
So we're most interested
in these guys.
And indeed, this
is the distribution
that [INAUDIBLE] set out to try
and measure in that experiment
that we just read
about last night.
So he wanted to know,
if you zoom in here--
because remember, this is even
narrower than I've actually
drawn.
But this distribution,
the probability
of a beneficial mutation
of magnitude s-- s, here 0,
s-- it's going to do something.
Many mutations that
are nearly neutral,
but it's going to
fall off in some way,
and they wanted to
try and measure this.
Now how many mutations
confer a 2% advantage, 4%,
for this particular
E. coli strain
in that particular environment?
But it turned out being
difficult to measure.
And what was the reason
that they gave for why
it was difficult to measure?
Somebody?
Anybody?
Please?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
But the equivalence
principle doesn't
say that they're all
equivalent necessarily.
AUDIENCE: Well, you can
make different [INAUDIBLE].
So there are different
distributions,
and they each have
their perimeters
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You can
pick perimeters
for each of them, such that
they will give you the same--
PROFESSOR: OK, that's right.
So what they found was
that different underlying
distributions-- this
probability distribution
for beneficial
mutations, function
of s-- different
underlying distributions
could give you the same final
output in their measurements.
But why was that?
Yeah, John?
AUDIENCE: The only thing you
can measure is what fixes.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So you can only
measure what it fixes,
or becomes significant
fraction population, 10%.
Only measure what
fixes or grows.
And what does that mean?
AUDIENCE: Well, it means that
you're not probing [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
It means that we're not probing
that distribution, and why not?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
But why is it that we only
see part of this distribution?
What was their--
AUDIENCE: We don't see
the ones that die out.
PROFESSOR: We don't see
And why is that they die out?
Or why is it that they--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, yeah.
Yes.
So the fact of
stochastic extinction
is very relevant here.
And I think that in this
paper they a little bit
underplay that aspect of it,
because they're primarily
arguing that it was
another effect that led
to this equivalence principle.
Right?
AUDIENCE: Competition.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
clonal interference.
I mean, that's why we
spent the last hour talking
about clonal interference.
So their argument
in this paper was
that, as a result of
clonal interference,
competition between
these different lineages,
then the distribution
of fitness effects
that you measure,
that fix, is not
the distribution that was
the underlying distribution.
Because less fit beneficial
mutations get out-competed.
But there's a very
important question,
which is, let's imagine
that let's have mu go to 0.
Or we go to small populations.
Let's say that after
reading his paper
I said, OK, well, yeah,
because of clonal interference
I can't measure this probability
distribution in the set up
that he used.
But maybe if I go to
small population sizes,
or I reduce the mutation
rate somehow-- magic--
then would this allow me to
measure that distribution?
So I'm going to ask
you guys to vote.
So mu, let's say.
Our experiment, I
have mu go to 0.
Does this mean that when
I then go do write CFP,
YFP, they're 50-50, and
then you start doing this.
And we measure the
slope to get s,
just like in this experiment.
If I plot the distribution
of resulting s's, no clonal
interference anymore, because
I've set mu equal to 0.
So this thing goes to infinity.
Do I recover the
underlying distribution?
Ready.
So P be measured,
as a function of s,
is it equal to the true one?
Question mark.
I'm going to give you 15
seconds to think about this.
Ready.
Three, two, one.
All right.
So we have, I'd say,
a majority of nos.
And can somebody say why not?
AUDIENCE: You can't really
see the established mutation.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
Because even if you don't
have clonal interference,
you still only see
the mutations that
survive so stochastic
extinction.
And I think this is a
really important point
that, at least in a first
reading of the paper,
you might not realize.
Yeah, John.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So in principle, we know that
the probability of survival
goes as s.
But you end up losing a
fair amount of information.
So for example, let's say that
this thing is an exponential.
So this is Pb of s.
Let's just say it's
an exponential.
And indeed, from some ideas
from extreme value theory,
there are arguments that maybe
this should be an exponential.
And if you're
curious about this,
come and ask me after class.
But let's just imagine that
this thing is exponential.
Now the question is
what would we actually
measure in this
experiment in the absence
of clonal interference?
Would we measure
a distribution--
would the distribution
be maximal
at 0 or at some other value?
Verbally, 0 or other value?
Ready, three, two, one.
AUDIENCE: Other value.
PROFESSOR: Other value.
And indeed, the probability
of surviving extinction,
remember this x1 goes as s
means that the distribution they
actually measure
will start at 0,
grow linearly,
and then fall off.
So this distribution
is essentially
like this distribution
of the convolution of two
exponentials, where this
thing goes up linearly,
and then curves off.
So I think that a very important
point to realize in all of this
is that this is probability
distribution that's
measured as a function of s with
no clonal interference, right?
So the statement
is that even if you
don't have any clonal
interference, already
you're going to measure
a peak distribution.
The underlying distribution
will be peaked at 0.
But what you measure
is always going
to be peaked somewhere else.
And indeed, if you
go and you look
in the paper at the measured
alpha as a function of s,
you see something that
looks kind of like this.
So it's a little bit difficult
to be absolutely certain.
What's going on is that in the
absence of clonal interference,
you get this.
With clonal interference, let's
say you have two mutations
and you want to know, OK,
what are you going to measure?
Well, you sample from
this distribution twice,
and you take the
larger of the two.
Because this
distribution is already
the probability distribution of
mutations that get established.
So then this is going to
grow as a quadratic here.
If you have more
clonal interference,
then this thing shifts to
the right and gets tighter.
So this is the process
by which you end up
with a peaked distribution.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to start in the first
15 minutes on Tuesday.
We'll talk about this
experiment a bit more.
And then we'll go on to think
about fitness landscapes
and the rate of evolution.
If you have any questions
about anything that we said,
please come on up.